let's talk about a video game which a
bunch of people are playing in an alpha
right now and which is great and posting
video content and all that sort of stuff
and we've had I think collectively over
the past couple of months sort of enough
time to play it past couple of weeks as
well and to sort of get to grips with it
Aaron you're basically like yourself and
Ryan are basically like the battlefield
experts here in the office and my cue
plays a bunch as well your are like war
for one expert as well yes I'm i love
Battlefield series I used to play in a
Vietnam clan I haven't been too into it
since battlefield 3 i'll say but i
thought i'd be cool to get the three of
us here together and just sort of like
talk shop like say okay what do we think
about bill one we've played like a long
put like hours into it at this stage and
some of us more than others I'm what do
we feel about Aaron first of all what's
your take on battlefield one my first
impression when I fired a battlefield
one we played it 83 and there was the
closed alpha build so there's a lot that
can still change between now and when
they're done was they listened to fan
feedback and they got it this time like
I think they understand like how to make
classes different they understand and
make objectives more fun they understand
like finally that people when they set
destruction they met building
destruction and grabbed affirmation just
everything at this stage feel so
competent and awesome the setting itself
it's a little funny it's definitely
things Rob Hamlin wanted out a piece
it's definitely fantasy world war one
like it's World War 2 in world war one
which is probably was necessary to
appeal to the court battle field fans
because they couldn't slap scopes and
automatic rifles right in authentic
World War one and I think that just
wouldn't have worked for this audience
yeah but it it feels very familiar some
of the things are will feel like Reese
kins to you but like not in a bad way at
all so like I'm interested to hear you
say that because you're somebody who has
been very critical of dice with
battlefield 3 and battlefield 4 and sort
of in in different ways what were the
core things you think they needed to
change with battlefield one like what
were the things coming at a battlefield
4 that you were like particularly
grieved about I actually really did like
three I thought it was a good compromise
although that was the moment when they
started caring more about graphics than
destruction
and then that carried through 24 where I
just felt for was very conceptually week
it just had no identity yeah they kind
of threw every point five or something
that kind of felt like it did feel like
3.5 and also just nothing felt very
unique in that game and one of my
biggest problems was that I feel like
they put all this thought into
l'évolution yes what they put their
thought into is the spectacle of
l'évolution and not the way that
LEvolution plays and a lot of the maps
including siege of Shanghai got real
boring after the LEvolution happened or
the LEvolution was crazy underwhelming
yeah so I think again like there's
another case where they just didn't
understand that people told them they
wanted destruction but they didn't
understand that they weren't just
talking about the spectacle of
destruction they were talking about
meaningful destruction and there's a lot
of that in this I was really surprised
Mike I remember you came on a couple of
weeks ago and talked about your
experience you know hiding in a you know
bunker shell basically and you know
while everything else is going on
ranging using that like little hole to
gain back your health or whatever and I
played a couple of matches recently and
couldn't believe how vastly it's like
it's what they were promising forever
but like the levels do actually change
by the end of it it's just like you know
the Zeppelin's crush this town there's
like potholes were there Warren potholes
before it looks almost indistinguishable
and what's your take on the sort of the
evolution the evolution as were in the
game and like I that actually manifests
like in terms of gameplay yeah at the
speeds what Aaron was just saying it's
not just like it's not just an aesthetic
thing anymore it's actually there's
functionality to it rights yeah I told
that story about like there's five of us
holding out in this outpost you can hear
artillery coming the sound design this
game even like in the alpha is unreal
it's very it's integral to how you play
and like what you know you're doing and
what you think you should do next and
what not but you hear the whistle the
artillery come in all other four other
people get killed I'm half dead but the
artillery self created a crater that I
crawled into didn't even have to fire my
gun I just waited there to hold down the
outpost until more people can get there
and like armored trucks and then there's
footage of me from when I'm sniping I'm
the scout Robin I were playing a match
back at e3 and went into the this like a
deck of this or like the loft of a barn
there's a small window with like a
little window sill over it said I can't
see anything all of a sudden half the
place gets torn away by the enemy team
because he knew I was in there so he was
just like pummeling it so I went prone
killed a few people the window
itself got torn out so I like had like a
sightline all of a sudden that wasn't
there five seconds ago yeah it's it's a
game of those types of stories like
we're all exchanging those stories which
like reminds me of kind of a bit like
bad company where you'd have you know
people been talking about they should go
back to my company for years and this
feels really close to we were kind of
talking about it earlier iron I had a
situation earlier which felt like it was
taken right at a Saving Private Ryan
where it was like oh I mean o'clock
tower sniping people I've had like real
trouble on the ground artillery sort of
like learning the pace of battlefield
again but often this clock tower open
this like windmill i guess it was and I
was feeling really confident there was a
bit of the wall broken off and it was a
good spot it was facing to control
points I kill like seven dudes in a row
which are like with the like leading
scope or you like shooting where they're
going to be which is so satisfied I also
added in bullet drag this time oh right
yeah really fascinating so the bullets
actually slowed down over distance wow
that's a cry didn't realize that
actually so it'll make it'll make it so
people who are snipers or scouts or or
even a support will have to be a little
bit more skills yeah I probably can't
murder you from halfway across the mouth
necessarily am and yeah I was killing
all these guy in you know as what
happens in your sniper eventually they
turn on you and start knowing where you
are and firing me and they were firing
on me and surprising me but I was still
like not getting killed and then I heard
that whistle yeah I'm gonna sing the
whole thing just blew off and it was
like you know what I was alright i don't
mind getting kill that way how do you
feel the vehicles are turning it this
time around are the vehicles that will
feel very familiar to battlefield 3 and
4 fans and you have a car which is
essentially the same as the MRAP right
which was just a light the white fast
vehicle you have I think a heavy tank
which is very similar to the amtrak from
robbery so you'll feel right at home if
you play battlefield and I I'm assuming
one of the things they wanted to
accomplish with this world war setting
was not to alienate battlefield fans and
they wanted things to still feel
familiar to them and so the vehicles
feel good they feel familiar there's
nothing like we didn't we haven't seen
the horse yet right yeah which is the
one thing where I don't think they could
I mean unless they make it exactly like
the motorcycle right yes you don't learn
about the horse though is kind of funny
I haven't i've noticed on this one yet
but usually when you walk away from
vehicles in battlefield
like 30 feet they explode so like are
you just like what do you do the horse
to they explode in a bunch of guts are
you like I'll you seen enough Bessie
like go off into the past you mean if it
you've you played enough red dead
redemption we just shoot them in the
head right ok walk with watch watch it
flop down and it does something about
this which feels very reminiscent of
thing 1942 where there are these massive
battles and in a way I'd maybe aspect as
I've been playing a lot of overwatch
recently and you feel like you're so
engaged in like the the victory but
there's so much about this game when you
do feel like you're a small cog in a big
battle field and is that ok do you think
Mike because obviously like feeling like
you're engaged in like your important
two successes is clearly important in
itself yeah I mean there's more than
there's so many ways to be integral to
your team just today they're just you
know like I was watching someone on
youtube or whatever but like sorry I let
III we were I was playing I was a scout
and I spent like maybe three total
minutes just running around the edge of
the map to get to the monastery it's
like it's like the the map that the
closed alpha had the San Quentin scar
and I spent about three minutes just
running around the edge didn't see
anybody didn't even nobody saw me from
what I know but then I got to the
monastery locked it down I didn't fire a
single shot for like five total minutes
but it still was a capture point which
is huge dear life yeah I mean like it's
so impressive how this the scale of
these battles changes despite the fact
that they are massive I'll be I prefer
playing as a scout if I haven't like
hinted at that yet um so I'll be I'll be
trying to hit someone from across the
map i'll be waiting for them to stand
still from like how many at 100 yards
away so i get the shot but then i'll go
into a farmhouse with my pistol out some
guy with a hatchet we'll just smoke me
the actual scale like switching from
close quarters to long-range to this
tank was coming at me and I ran behind a
wall and I still wasn't used to
destructible environments yes was like
all right I'm safe I'm just gonna try to
play CAD miles from this wall no he just
blew it up and I was staring him in the
face it's just the different encounters
that you come across and like you said
the stories you come out from these
matches with it's it's it's you know
it's closed alpha but it's enticing it's
kind of encouraging I like the fact that
it's not the sterile thing you jump into
every time you know I call of duty I
haven't played infinite warfare yet
obviously but you jump into these
matches and it's the same thing over and
over it's just twitch gameplay you're
trying to get like you're trying to get
this many kills trying to you know be
number one of the ranks but then this
there are so many different ways to get
point to your team and
kind of aid the effort like whether it's
just contributing fire to an airship or
guiding a tank into the right outpost at
the right time to just lock it down for
there's 10 seconds more stuff like that
it's it's so cool to see how these
battles can unfold with you like in
different roles yeah and that's the way
it kind of feels different to me is that
we look a lot of footage of this game
and I certainly felt this way until I
got hands-on with it was that I would
like I get it it looks like a kind of a
reskin the battles are slightly bigger
but there is a totally different paces
like I feel like my time to death is
like way longer like I'm existing in the
world a lot more a lot of this in a way
that reminds me of like battlefield to a
lot as well yeah in that point I think a
lot of this is a return to what was good
about previous battlefields I feel like
they went through the the line and just
picked out the good bits of everything
and then put it into this game so time
to kill is longer which is refreshing
given more modern games they went back
to at least in the Alpha class-based
right oh you don't have the carbines of
for that make everybody do everything
you really do have to stick within your
class and roll and if a tank rolls up on
you as a medic yeah there's not a lot
you can do about it yeah you got to
choose better and move better um the
Zeppelin's interesting actually the
Zeppelin's the first time in this game
where and it is similar to the ac-130
but as opposed to being tied to a base
it's tied to the losing team yeah and
it's the first time I think that they've
done something to try and help matches
balance better it's interesting though
because it's a it's a decision you have
to make if you get into the Zeppelin you
can destroy most of the map hmm but you
can't capture capture ball yes so you'll
still lose from on high it's it's a Liz
it's a balance is there to help you but
it won't win the match for you I liked
how when it happens as the sort of
attacking team it was almost it's got
enough to stop with all the overwatch
references but it reminded me of when my
tracer runs into the back you team where
suddenly have this thing you have to
worry about you didn't have to worry
about before like there's this massive
hulking thing that's like making its way
across the map and it's even if you're
not like attacking it all the time
you're like getting to it like you're
like a lot I'm right beside like a you
know whatever like a big gun like a
standing gun I should go so I take a
couple of shots it's like on your mind
the whole time a menace yeah like a
menace exactly there was times I was
running a lot
and I was looking at it and I'm like
don't hit me don't hit me down here and
you can see it kind of gone boom boy
like hitting near you and I was like
like and then it like made me change the
direction I was going in to try and get
to the objective so yeah it's like it's
a really interesting like intimidating
sort of factor there I'm like it's one
of those moments right i think it was
like maybe wasn't caspian border what
was the one with the with the large
telephone pole in the middle of it was
that that was cuz ya ya so I'm ever like
seeing that fall down over the first
time was like wow and like just sitting
back gone that's awesome mama that's
evident blow up it was like it was like
hell was like wait again and I saw like
cars driving away trying to get away
from it and it's just awful like it's
just this flaming like mass and then the
fact that like later then in that map I
was trying to like get one of the
objectives with with a little battalion
and or a squad and like we were just
like literally jumping over parts of the
thing that I'd like torn this the
village apart it's just I yeah it's
interesting in so many ways that I
wasn't really expecting yeah Rob
handlery had mentioned the idea that if
you're driving the Zeppelin you know
it's about to go down try to position it
in a way that you know you're losing the
airship you might as well try to make it
more difficult the other team to like
get to a crucial checkpoint if possible
you know like position it so it's gonna
be this choke point it'd be this like
almost new French like a new trench
almost yeah and that's the thing most
shooters nowadays are very reactionary
right um there's more for thought in
this now just based just based on the
closed alpha that feels like placement
is so much more important it's not
necessarily lining up the right shot
it's like I don't know mind it was like
the Wayne Gretzky quote says like good
players go where the puck is great
players go with the pucks gonna be yeah
so I feel like battlefield like it's
returning for those roots like Aaron
said where it's more about like thinking
through a few moves in like where you
can be not necessarily to get like two
or three kills but where you can be too
kind of actually impact the flow of the
battle in the next five minutes and
that's like a really refreshing thing in
the modern shooter landscape it's gonna
be super interesting to see what they do
with the single-player aspect of this
last thought on this Aaron what do you
think what else do you want to see from
this obviously alpha closed off is
running at the moment they're probably
gonna do more betas and reveal more
multiplayer stuff what what else would
you like them to introduce or what would
you like them to focus on I think this
map in the closed alpha is technically
extremely competent and everything
mostly like feels great to play with
sounds great
I haven't seen I mean we've only seen
one map I want to see a map that gives
me that sensation we got the first time
we jumped off damn a vampy oh my god yes
like I don't think battlefields it has
done that since damavand peak right just
some why not something that just like
blows you away that you've never seen
before yeah I think you always want that
from a game so I think at this stage
they have technical competence they've
taken the best bits of other
battlefields and put them in place
everything's in line right now for them
to really just blow you away with
something and I don't haven't seen that
something just yet but I you know the
Zeppelin's probably the closest for
today but I'm excited to see what would
a what else they have up their sleeve
that'd be cool yeah so messed up some
messed up maps you'll have to see I mean
they've it's been a lot of diversity in
a map Center and what they've shown the
trailer so I don't know maybe we'll get
something cool they're both thank you
both for coming on talking about the
battlefield I don't think it'll be the
last time I'm going to be talking about
it this year so I look forward to
getting both on in the future in the
document
you